hey everybody so for the people that
don't know who gary is which I'm sure
it's probably only maybe one or two
people here who doesn't know my spiel
raise your hand it's okay oh we got one
we got Oh about you Michael mandate but
my mom mom keep going don't be scared
look at that all content is butyl time
somebody's gonna be all content is new
content easy there so for people that
don't know Gary can you give us a quick
two-minute three-minute rundown of who
you are and why you're the og of social
media I'm an entrepreneur for for the
ones that don't know who I am I've
sorted for the ones that have hurt us a
bunch I hope you know i was born in the
former Soviet Union came here as a kid
live the studio of our big queens we
place a small on the stage along
and my family moved to New Jersey
because my dad started working at a
liquor store and my dad emociones a
small inner source regular Jersey I
gross brunch for a living Santa's
baseball cards fell of wine the notion
people collecting it when I'm sixteen
seventeen launched ecommerce website
very early on in 1996 fill my dad's
family with their services to Murphy to
a single email business starting YouTube
videos someone's after you two came out
became somewhat there that famous
because of that jump on Twitter early on
we came over 2500 saw people on your
actually came in all of your clothes and
and then it started investing in things
like Twitter and Tumblr and we were just
kind of a marketer businessman started
an agency for you so my brother rejects
we visually just called mana vidya last
few years we've got 22 300 people so
kind of my second business building that
kind of range so much more to digest man
[ __ ]
so I guess so you know what we do here
is owned we'd love to bring
entrepreneurs and home and shot callers
like like mr. gary vaynerchuk to the
community and let people have hedge so
for the first 30 minutes or so I'm going
to ask me a couple questions probably
three or four and then I'll hold out the
crowd so you can get three or four
questions in their number one we're
going to ask for money you're not gonna
get you might have some fries he does
give you money if a star get sent the
same
oh I don't even like the name you know
so before we did it to them you let's
let's just get into it share this on
social media so um about I would say a
few weeks ago Beyonce drop the album
yeah and she did it without telling
anybody yeah of course he has a big huge
brand as you can exploit egg but on how
he's so to play a part in it like how
important was it for her to have that
social media I don't think believe it or
not big for social i think it helped
that it was all over itunes and in front
of all our faces i'm even have to be at
once for us and know about it so i would
say so we played a huge part about I
don't think beyonce does social well to
be honest with you I think it's kind of
lead us the best of engaging with her
community or doing anything different on
social that she does a traditional media
so I'm being social had a lot of doing
that I think what I'd love to do with it
was she's [ __ ] legit has been famous
for a long [ __ ] time and put out a
lot of good content so I want to
oversell the social dessert social
deserves credit for me right who had no
platform and nobody knew and I used the
tools to build myself up Beyonce at this
level I think had more to do with the
exposure she was able to get from itunes
and then sort of that we're social came
in is it might be Jackson the same thing
ten years ago what so he didn't Beyonce
was when that came out people found it
interesting and what you
really is guys the way at least I think
about it is it the plumbing for word of
mouth in our society right so he is
flying right and we'd love to tell each
other things and so what happened was as
I caught buzz social amplify the
awareness so maybe there was an
awareness factor may be whether it was
more or faster that's where social
played into a play but she had the grand
advocated the structure for that to be
successful maybe people bother albums
quicker because they became aware of it
quicker in their fees because of social
but I wouldn't save Social some of those
hours so you think socialblade more of I
guess it's not really a tabbed and it
was really just a right hook for you can
see it really engage them leave that as
a catalyst of several hours I think
we're about self stuff I always have I
think anybody here if your salesperson
business person live in the world you
realize that you every person here has
bought has been their hard-earned money
on things because somebody they trust or
no said something was good but there was
a restaurant an album of beverage
whatever it is we are now living in a
world where we all think that our word
of mouth is valuable right like we
default like if we're all watching the
same show like we're all going to watch
the Super Bowl and when something
happens you leave here entitled to
without your phone and give your two
cents on that [ __ ] cash
titan to our two cents that we never had
before and so it's creating more volume
of word of mouth we're consuming each
others opinions and thoughts it's
changing the course of the way to make
decisions not only about what we buy how
we live it's very intriguing times right
now how our opinions are being formed by
each other not just fine you know the
mainstream media so on the last
interview we had we talked about a
return of investment associate and how
people were playing out lazy like they
didn't really want to put in that
engagement yeah for further people to
add families and have full-time jobs
that are trying another leverage social
yeah how can I go about training time to
get themselves a position right okay sit
out time Oh excellent work let's define
social right let's take a step back and
ranchers much to get everybody on the
same page here's how I because of
gatorade there's people that create
contact baidu lot right i thought i'm
going to write something i'm gonna be a
video i'm going to put it out there
there's people that consume content and
comment on it all of us do that right
you see something you like it you
pardoned you say something reply with we
we we jump on top of our content
I was established and then there's the
third car which is the only part I don't
do well which is generous people PJ
content right now to me that's the one
that's most interesting for everybody in
the room if you want enough time the
notion that in curating content that
you're consuming all day and then you're
repassing on information that DJ booth I
think that's a very attractive thing I
don't do that a lot I mean a lot of you
follow me on Twitter I've put out a
hundred and fifteen thousand tweets in
my life the amount of times that they've
been retweet or links oven people stop
has been very minimum it's not my
strength but there's plenty of people I
think Jason Herr Schwarz femaleness
right to me a few of that guy use but
he's got a great email list now he spent
a lot of time teaching he's consuming
content for seven hours a day so that he
can send email that has 11 links on it
in the morning I find that massively
valuable if you're struggling to figure
out out there what you want to say
please give a lot of thought to wait a
minute I can consume and then put out
the best up or my two cents on top up so
those are the three ways to kind of play
in social if you have time well you may
not be good you may be no it's like you
if you don't time to exercise you're not
going to have [ __ ] muscles right
you know I can't help you if you're
deciding to do something else listen I
don't know everybody situation there's
plenty people here who have two jobs and
rent and a student loan and I can't sit
here and say figure it out I get it you
only sleeping four hours in bed and
begin with to just get by I can't sit on
my high horse here to like do this do
that but here's what I will say we have
never lived in a time like this before
the Internet here's an example I just
left my office I was in being with seven
of the vine celebrities that I represent
for the ones that intimately know me
know that I have a vine talent agency
called rape story you'd represent 25 by
celebrities I'm sitting in a room right
now with 70 right before I got here kids
that one year ago sat in front of me and
if we were reminiscing about some of the
stories I told them and they were like
youth one guy riding from Boston he was
like you told me I could make a living
by making vine videos and I left you and
I was like ass
Eddie goes and now I'm inmate $80,000 in
the last you know here you know so i SAT
there and I was thinking it's incredible
you at the time or these six teenagers
that I'm just hanging out with some of
that we're going to make six figures
this year I'm making six-second videos
right I mean literally one guy was based
in for 12 bucks an hour we decided a
check for a hundred thousand dollars
from for brands to make these ten videos
we live in a crazy world we live in a
world where an Internet bring about mine
snapchat Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram in the world word of
the Internet is a platform that all of
us have access to and if we can create
something people want on it in any of
those platforms are ready any other way
we have a chance to be funny Allen
parents and our Greek randoms did not
have that option if they were working a
full-time job they didn't have the
option to come home at seven pm and the
confines of their home build their
future and we do use on the side if
you're willing to cut out the hour of
playing madden or going bowling
watching voice you know you gotta make
those decisions for me going back to the
first book I will crush it I think we're
so damn lucky to have this opportunity
that if you won't love what you've got
going on that you have to allocate an
hour two or three or four for how much
hustle you can put in at night when you
get home to try to do one of these
things whether it's writing or making
videos for creating something we're just
very fortunate we're very fortunate
because every one of the kids in my
office right now we're in school or have
a job and what you've been able to do
this without the internet and vine they
wouldn't have been able to start their
money people used to have dreams like
I'm gonna start a coffee shop right
we're honest our liquor store or a like
that was money and a limited time like
you can was not practical in 1992 do
your thing it's very practical for us to
do our thing that is a big ass feel that
simpler we've added and don't have too
much time and I go I used to death
dating zone applications my father well
I grew sweet maybe i'll post up no
baby's mother jabs but at the scheduled
for man i I am laughing because I think
so he was human and I think schedule I
in front your schedule
and something that happens dude look
Nelson Mandela passes away you can
assure truth it's later the other
scheduled be my final [ __ ]
even worse than that you know that was
at least borderline consumable after the
Boston Massacre the bomb the amount of
friends that I have that scheduled
tweets like literally three minutes
after [ __ ] an explosion of the Boston
Marathon there Hawking their [ __ ] by my
book do this listen all of you know I've
been paid by the [ __ ] out my book for
six months just like that happen I'm
gonna do a minute later it's tacky it's
inappropriate and I need scheduled
tweets or anything of that nature
creates the ability for you now become
human which can dilute all your efforts
very quickly whatever you said sometimes
to be human exec best value I take
advantage of schedules we have 11 I mean
that's how I will the reason I believe
little Egypt so many of you and engage
and consume and we went to go see Aaron
foster whose mama shooting at is this on
five minutes [ __ ] I'm like when I'm
gonna meet and I gonna take a piss I
take my phone out on walking to the
bathroom and try to reply to something
like if you injure cited by animals on
the way here I looks like 11 minutes
reading what are you all saying about
this talk so i should have like called
somebody out but I'm running late so I
haven't thrown my
my car and I'm really on the way here
but I want to normally spent those 11
minutes and I think listen there's no
substitution for putting in the work
either you've got to do this or you're
not if you're looking for automatics
don't care about social you advertise it
do banner retargeting search engine
optimization at SC AB an email marketing
do this stuff that's ok if you don't act
human this social human period or you'll
lose so with it what it might mean even
correct yeah that you remember in
savings in a driver lost elated you know
just a moment I'm right like I don't
know boat I don't just like I i I'm so
thankful that people would drive to come
and see me talk or show me it's Friday
night like you guys can all be doing a
lot of cool ass [ __ ] tonight right and
the families and all this stuff and like
people coming on their second third and
all the way to back way they're 15 times
seeing me speak do you know what that
feels like our Facebook I'm grateful and
so if people going to do that I'm gonna
take three minutes to read what people
say and the 10 seconds to smile back and
say thank you you know and so I'm not
unaware of how gift that I've been to be
able to have a room show up and hear and
talk and I'm that's just a blessing and
I take it very seriously and I get very
mad at people I did what I had 100
followers when i had a hundred followers
on twitter i was like on drink people
when I said this is salsa right amount
of people that because they see other
people have a million don't respect the
572 followers they have and then worried
about how am I going to get to a million
that's dumb thinking the the reason
you're not getting to a thousand is
because you're not respecting your 572
the way I got two million was respecting
my 40 which then turned into my 80 which
I turned by 160 oh so we don't we
actually begin to be a Jason how hands
and he releases a piece talking about
you and how you know you to monetizing
on YouTube might not be a vesting yep
here you're always constantly dropping
videos drop in Unum post how do you use
those things to monetize on your houses
it's those things are really belong to
you what you can't do that
this is for people confused I am
thrilled to do anything anywhere if it's
bringing me awareness to convert later
down the line the biggest problem right
now in the game is that everybody wants
last point of distribution attribution
to their sale what this talk do for me
my like it did the books I got under
books it's me giving you love as I like
you write your crew it's three people
you're going to know a little bit more
for the next time it's the 11 people
that didn't know me at all [ __ ] you guys
so I'm not worrying about great about
what this specific hour on Friday night
where my wife is like what are you doing
like I thought you're gonna be the world
about Friday's what's going to do for me
this moment I'm worried about what it's
going to do for you long term the reason
I ran out of medium is I reading the
piece on medium it will go viral and
then everybody that goes to medium com
they see one of the top ten most you
know read articles that day and there's
a lot of people going to medium that huh
that I've never heard of me like follow
them like a ninety-five percent of
people still don't know who I am so the
reason I write for media and the reason
I trained for Lincoln's influence or
program is when I did something that
goes viral they have triggers that allow
people who never heard of me if you were
a one of the five top articles on
linkedin if you've read is something
length and articles you see on the right
side they show the top 5 articles that
then that's allowing you to reach people
that have never heard of me so the
reason I do things like YouTube when oh
I hope everybody's on it and I've
discovered you do things and it's crazy
to think only one chess move nobody here
really lives their lives like everything
do at that moment was the ROI of that I
understand that I can't convert on my
website at that moment but if you build
like I'm just trying to fry bigger fish
if I'm trying to build a big enough
brand I get paid seventy thousand
dollars to give a why our keynote I
would never get that if I was worried
about selling like four dollar ebooks on
my [ __ ] domain page so so I'm just
playing long game I think we're all a
lot gonder you know I mean I really who
here is retiring in the next 10 years I
mean I don't mean who gonna [ __ ] kill
it and retire old inner finish
Oh
I don't believe so i'll leave that one
job but the rest of us are all planning
on grinding is working a decade from now
do you want a bowl with like 10 years
ago like we weren't even fully like a
plated cell phone down yeah little smart
let alone social there was no Facebook
there was no YouTube it exists so I
think long term I think really long term
I'm not worried about tomorrow you know
and so i made so many my decisions on
that which is why it's confusing to most
but i just want to let the cards play
out the way they do it why I do a lot of
stuff like this to document it to even
for the next generation see that you can
also win by running the marathon you
don't need to sell Instagram for a
billion dollars 500 days in everybody's
trying to chase that one in a trillion
there's just such a guaranteed way put
in the work and you bring in quality and
you keep doing it and grind a new hustle
day in and day out that's how many more
people win and succeed that the one offs
that happened once a generation that
science alone do all previous interview
when you mention up don't taste the
quake dollar taste a long dollar like
that man thank you said will be the
dollar bill
when you can taste the hundred-dollar
bill next week yeah guys up listen I'm
hyper and all that but God my patient
because you got time and for me to be
honest with you a lot much more about I
legacy that my currency like it's a big
thing for me like doing it the right way
matters there's a lot of people making
money on the internet the internet
marketing and and their spouses and
significant others are embarrassed how
they make them cash right there's a lot
of cheap ways to make a quick buck I
know plenty of people that have got
beautiful watches and fast [ __ ] cars
and houses and they just spam their way
there and they're not proud and look
when Jimmy rock whatever they rock oh
right like that you guys don't talk
about the tweet with a girl like you
know I remember that days when I was all
going on everybody was freaking out on
Twitter and I mean she's gonna get fired
she's going to get fired right for her
tweet her racist tweet i was like people
she's the last thing this woman has to
worry about is her being fired this is
her legacy from the rest of her life
these eight billion particles from
that's her children one day
I did though once a thought next one
ninety-two seven people over screw your
grandfather was racist right but nobody
knows it because it's lost in history
bastrop got changed all the dumb [ __ ]
that our parents and grandparents and
great breakers in lost in history change
telephone would change the game right
all the dump ship we're doing documented
pictures tweets thought I remember I
remember take my heart after that
verdict in there i was reading tweets I
was a dma my friends are like you're
gonna regret that one you're gonna
regret I don't regret that one I don't
think people are thinking about like I
see enough this is a one game in
evolution when you're thirteen year old
granddaughter rolls off on you in 40
years it's like grandpa and you say this
you're like [ __ ] so I think about
everything like that I think wall turn I
think how do I remember something about
right now I'm thinking about who's to be
watching this video what can I say that
why change them might help them might
even make one smarter move that's what
I'm looking for that's that's what I
want oh that's how we spoke also you
spoke about quality over plans
when it comes to mentions and you know
shouts on Twitter about social media
Justin Bieber just got arrested yeah but
you're in craziness that we would all
have to do it and not being cool yeah
exactly it is right now because those
are negative mentions but will will be
at the table t1 honey poorly and
positively like let's not be confused
right there's certain devil that loves
at and his bad boy buddy you know you
don't girls off with your 16-minute in
fashion you know it's like you know
there's certain things that are positive
but I'm a full-service to plenty of
negative of losing sponsorship
opportunities I mansions meetings with
these major brands I mean he's you know
he's losing money it bachelor gives him
having that anymore he's got so much of
it he's a kid is going through his
normal things I mean this is stuff from
seeing what you know everybody worries
about this is going to affect my son I
think what parents allow Justin Bieber
to raise their child right like I ain't
like like Bieber's gonna be fine what
I'm going mad about is all the parents
that are tweeting like this is terrible
you know he's a huge influence on my
daughter on the floor terrible like you
makes one that he's not driving but you
think your daughter is now we smoked in
and drive a Lamborghini
I'll be mad parents in general right
like I'm computers a lot like this girl
she's bad right to produce bad if I kids
on this all days I'm a parent I'm like
when your chops 11 it's called a
dictatorship you did whatever you want
right and of course you force you wanna
like not make it to netherlands now but
there's just so much miss Gaius snatch
at I started talking about snapchat two
years ago and its value and why I
thought it was going to be big I had a
lot of email from parents saying things
like gallery you can't be promoting
snapchat all the kids are sexting on it
there's some naked pictures too I would
provide real calm like dear mrs.
Thompson just your son your total son
you just mentioned does he have a
smartphone yes like does he have a wife
I like using internet access yes dear
mrs. Thompson you did not worry about
[ __ ] snapchat your son
haha
porsche my facebooks going to be a
business in to be here something okay I
mean like you know we just read
headlines like and there's too much have
I I listen I realize this as I remember
whatever recent facebook will be out of
business in three years after came out
just like my space where they didn't
look into was who's running the company
my say-so total corporation this is they
little bit they don't take in the death
of the barrels so you know I'm be in
front listen here's what's gonna happen
shorter knees they lose out on millions
of dollars on on sponsorship
opportunities the worst thing that would
happen to him is scooter braun we
discovered him who you know i should say
his friend of mine is a good guy did you
know scooter really wants to help him
and you know and if he chooses scooter
his life that would be bad it's been a
very positive influence in my opinion to
the benefit of scooters about Mother
Teresa but you know the long-term
yeah you can find a few cleans up his
life some people do some people tell so
there's a lot of you people that found
us you know the fast daughter then came
to this event because of you so you're
out dad alright so a lot of people don't
know about our last questions question
which is very answer but we might seem
to help you might not but I wanted to
hear it and so you have the twenty
twelve round table you get to pick up
somebody in hip hop and some of your
business 24 hours to pick their brains
who is in life is it still Vince McMahon
Paris huawei so settle this then still
always sits at my table I think Vince
McMahon I think storytelling is what
sells products me that fact of Vince
McMahon consolidated industry and sell
sweets two men about men running around
they spring
I think you know people the
million-dollar business comments so
opera right accidentally so a radical
you know what storytelling on the WWE
level i think is very very very
impressive you know why throw into i
don't care as one of you know I
liquidator who to give us the sense of
traffic your way but you know I really
really really really like to a throw-in
Kendrick Lamar now here's why what he
way he's been doing more last six months
about the way his position is brand and
his competitive nature like I so get I
so get the notion of you know I really
want every person in this room right now
to have the best life ever to build the
biggest businesses of all time all that
as long as my it's just a little bit
bigger
and not just my competitive spirit and I
think that you know if I had the skills
that can turn had that what he's been
doing by showing up on other people's
albums with the pure intent to clown
them on their own track there's
something competitive about that that I
liked and I'd want to tap into that
conversation and get them to others I
think i'm talking about what he's been
doing the whole year right I think he's
just a very smart way his position
Graham and I haven't no I loved the
limelight I love the fact that when he's
on that our albums better artist better
leaders you can literally feel him
elevating his game on the same way like
to me like I want the chip to me it's
about the climb right the reason I can
be patient and long-term and all that
stuff I speak to you guys is I actually
don't like the victory I know me any Sam
think the charming he's caught up all
the 96 that I was counting right like I
well the climb like I love being a Jets
fan I'm not [ __ ] losing I will
I do I like the climb I like the client
so much and so just go chase I don't do
I think you know once you get the order
something I've got my wife and so much
honey every time on vacation I'm so
pumped a week before literally literally
the wheels hit the ground and I look at
art of like there's something just ran
wire I love it I love going into the
agency world if you read the articles
about later be in 2009 Oh guarantee just
because you've got 800,000 Twitter
followers thinks it's gonna be so easy
to build an agency these are real
companies Gary you know this is real
[ __ ] now I [ __ ] it I just beat that [ __ ]
I get so hot like sometimes forced or
I'll just go to Amazon and read my one
star reviews of my book
[ __ ] what's
look I read every single better review
of Russia and thank you copy my first
two books just getting pumped without a
job you know I love you but Resta mated
I love with it I love being trolled I
love when people say that I don't have
it I [ __ ] I'll never get it there I
can't that feeds the living [ __ ] I mean
just as an assessment of how much work
you put into social media oh we
purchased your book I think I think we
pre-purchased it like October and we
didn't get until the last week of
messier we had home teeth with a company
called in the cemetery man Gary did such
a great job yo so that's insane yeah
i'll test me today i'm a little matter
what helps your [ __ ] it up
yeah I mean I love that I love that they
were like listen here's how you last two
books open I'm like I'm telling you it's
going better I feel good about this one
like never know every author says that
so like yeah there was a part of you
that love that I like that people won't
get their books if you were getting
frustrated but yeah there's nothing you
know for me everybody why are different
ways I don't feel like I deserve
anything let me tell you one thing that
really pisses me off that startup
culture right now everybody you starting
a company right now because of this
bubble we're living in feels like
they're entitled to customers right I
don't feel entitled to anything starting
tomorrow morning everything I've done
forever before I feel like type in 0
it's natural for me to working right I
feel like all the good content all of
the interviews and all of the stuff I've
done as soon as I walked in here I felt
like that meant nothing but i had to a
better job again with your sony two
nights ago 15 times whenever I got to do
it again I've got to bring something out
I gotta talk about something different
for that individual person and for the
collective because because I'm thankful
and I'm just not I just entitlement
pisses me off to no end I think we're
living through a huge entitlement push
right now like how the [ __ ] they
launched an app good we want a [ __ ]
cookie like
now going to customers now deliver value
like goal of your business there's other
there's a shocking entitlement factor
right now everybody thinks just because
you were smart enough to start an
internet business power go starting to
nervous everybody's got a nap
everybody's got a business card keep
your [ __ ] business card
so we select the people take the punches
to the realest animals play thank you
now we're going to take more questions
organize a question please line up right
alongside work for we get a mortgage for
you dad
it up to ya just general shape on sat
okay so just so you're talking about the
negative like artists ism that you get
now is how do you like you know it helps
your motivation how do you feel about
you know for all of us or for you like
directly responding to negative
criticism or comments on articles or
anything I think a lot of people here
that you don't know and that's my first
food as a matter fact I've spent a lot
of time in the last 12 months trying to
do a better job responding the positive
feedback because I was just spending all
my time we're stop feeding the trolls
right like feeding the negative instead
of like thanking the positive you can
get caught in that game listen let me
start let me start with a very different
angle on why I respond to people's David
comments because for the most part I
believe that they believe it like I
think I believe that they think I stink
or that this was bad or I was wrong on
this so the first thing I would say is
I'm a little bit concerned that all of a
sudden anybody disagrees with you or
leaves a negative comment is it true I
look at it as somebody who just has a
different point of view and I respect if
I would be if I'm gonna take all the
athletes I'm gonna take the negative B
lab not to mention you can learn from it
my knees and feet
last eight years on the internet has
formed I have changed uncertain things
like you know I've done tighter like I
try not to exaggerate ever because
everything's on the record like I'm
doing everything I've got better because
of it so the first thing I would say to
you man is you know if somebody's
malicious or using slurs or
inappropriate actually just dead the
variable but you know first of all you
should respect somebody else's point of
view I think it's healthy for you to
address in and engage it can teach you
something I think it has enormous value
I mean I respond to my negativity an
awful lot I would tell you that my ten
biggest fans started off a [ __ ] you Gary
I think that there's a lot of value in
navigation I mean that's it the good
with the bad that is beneficial I've
around that more people reading into an
enemy agent cooler
oh my name is ova ova Gerald I I bet all
through your books they'll both they all
do and we're great elector last one the
best and on my question is what do you
think the implications that the new
rules on how funding would have on
social media and you need the jobs act
like a fact that we get all but five
hundred bucks an hour to start up yeah
absolutely I think it's gonna be there's
any more [ __ ] product I mean I think
we're going to start seeing even more
crap because everyone just like what
everybody saw the social network and
what happened Facebook anybody decide
that they were not to the door and we're
going to start a company the same things
about to happen with the best thing
right just cuz they you know they read
like this soul and when uber goes public
ago said Garrity mate you know I was a
women I want to do that and so a lot of
people are going to take advantage of
the fact that before we get a good 25
and 50 thousand other checks for me and
not everybody had the skills to build a
bit of product or be able to sell
somebody to write that kind of chat but
put it on Kickstarter like website and
getting 500 bucks or 150 we're all the
play Bob we're all going to everyone
considerably his app I'm going to
uncomment with almond 800,000 back row
that's going to be with to swing the
supply-demand a more crap product so i
think the first issue believe will
happen is a locking rhythms lotta money
it will be even worse i'm completely
positive one of the products to blow off
of you well and then that love stories
are they everybody knows me more money
right now you had a lot of very average
of below average product that's talent
there is news source backdrop is our
degrees now cover five six years ago is
a lot of dumb bunny there's a lot of
Isaac me right stupid chefs everything
for so smart I mean contentious now
we're going to have even more dumb on
unlimited on money right everybody put
either 50 bucks I think we're going to
see him look like a kickstart if you
watched a starter look at the products
you've got a lot of great product but my
percentage it's changed as become more
mass and so I'm concerned that you know
I hope people just I'm very worried that
it's going to be a lot of attacks on the
dreamers I'm very concerned about it we
might one
for the checks some things that have no
prayer so I'm thinking you know it's
funny but that I've been thinking about
this a lot how do I like help without
coming across like a cynic because I'm
in that game right I haven't really
figured it out again but you know on the
flipside being an optimist everything
hope there are 20 to 100 companies that
are formed that would have never had a
chance because they're like two kids in
Kansas that would have not had access
below in the way that Kickstarter has
done some great stuff is I what I
actually think is going to happen is
what happened d Internet bubble I think
I'm front there's going to be a frenzy
think a lot of people lose money the
lead correction will calm down and I
think it's going to be much more
beneficial and exciting in 2020 then it
will be for the next half decade thank
you yeah big lesson I think that's a
thanks only choice first of all diving
winning friends fasho i drove down from
Vermont to see you and I wanted to start
off with a thank-you because the first
chapter of javits revered right hook we
spent twenty-five dollars on advertising
and got over 20,000 engagements and
Facebook was measuring our CPC at zero
sense it's actually less than Pena
doesn't measure anymore that's because
of you and have date I want to say after
oh but you you talk about in your
content in your books everywhere you
talk about giving value building an
audience by giving value and it kind of
comes back in a variety of different
ways and that's what we do we are
businesses in three pieces and we give
value in three very different ways to
three very different audiences with in
one industry but it's focused on
partnerships to okay how do you form
your partnerships how do you structure
those how do you start them how how do
you get to a place where you're working
with someone on a regular basis
cohesively what are you looking for me
myself you yourself so partnerships come
in so many ways and forms right like to
partnerships I've only had to my dad and
my brother right partnerships coming in
form of you know we've been touring my
employees where it's not about the
business about it's a relationship
partnership are you talking about the
actual business way no
lo guys other than that but less
specific so we ago I have my business
partner and then we have a few equity
partners but one of the things that we
do is kind of act as a digital agency
for people who are influential in our
space and so we started by interviewing
them on our podcast and they started
asking us for four things that we were
already planning to give but they
started knocking on her door wanting it
now and we want to provide them now so
we're trying to keep up with their need
and grow with it but there's all these
different types of partnerships so how
do you ceiling for other partners to
provide the services that these google
offers you can't get some YY content
partnerships audience partnerships
mutual win-win value-driven how do you
the my biggest problem with something
like that for me you may not have people
have this month with his house policeman
for me is that there's a real specific
reason that I was a dnf student you know
people always think it was cuz oh he
must have been so entrepreneur that he
didn't give up right truth is like I
really hate details right I don't like
them all that much and so from you to do
a true partnership I need to dig I'm
gonna put my name on something and say
hey we're put this guy hey work with
this girl I had to dig I didn't need to
know and so I just stay away from a lot
of stuff because I'm all the time or
patience to actually put in all the
world to get it give that recommendation
to answer your question
first of all you to put in the work that
won't you send these people to that they
actually can execute on it right because
a lot of faking going on out there I
want to bother with you here's revenue I
would do the order to figure out who's
the best in class to provide value for
the people to transcend and then once
you find them you need to go to that
individual or organization and provide
that more value than they're providing
to you and so one of the ways to do that
is to do a referral to them without
asking for any referral fee because now
they don't think you're just trying to
cite that a 20-percent big for just
seven eight email right like people
always are like Gary one of those sales
for you I don't need your [ __ ] sales
right like I'm you twenty percent me to
get it anyway thanks Joe you know it so
and so I think that's what I would do I
would audit when you think is best and
then I think you should attack them and
provide that more value than you're
asking thank you very much the value
addition of irritation
my name is Andrew and I love what you do
and I watched at least six hours of your
presentations the different companies
online and one of the things that you
talk a lot about its contents yes
creating context with individuals in and
you personalize it with even individuals
in the audience yes just I guess even
give some additional tips to that
present day like how do you get contacts
now you know context is around this
about hops right on even look like I to
convert I mean when I sit down to signal
I look at as many of your faces as I
could to try to demo up this audience
right like context is at all times you
know I'm always thinking about context I
mean context I think is the bedrock of a
good storytelling good salesmanship good
providing value so you know I don't know
how to go deeper to what I'm talking
about but here's what I would say it's
kind of like it's religion versus in
church right like the religion doesn't
change but the way you build a church
has a lot to the community and where you
are you might throw my both outdoor
church in a warm weather place you know
like there's just nuances so to me I'm
always in context mode right like where
do you comfort that challenge from
Vermont and that literally was a
contextual spent in my mind you said
into not handy like I think about [ __ ]
like that I'm serious I'm contacting at
all times what people are giving me so
that when I give in return it has a
better chance of landing on the spot
nobody's I talk a lot about context
right now is because social media is
bold into one thing and the difference
between Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram
is severe and I see a lot of you in your
organization's use products that are
automated to take a picture and put it
everywhere you got a facebook in your
Twitter attached facebook just asked us
all to attach our instagrams to our face
sucks most people said yes they were
pumped i was going to be easier I said
[ __ ] no right because I know that a
picture that works on facebook that's
typically the one that does an Instagram
what time you're doing it is a piece of
contacts you know like when I'm trying
to hit Hustler's and like motivate
entrepreneurs I'm posting that thing at
eleven fifty Eastern if I'm trying to
hit that's over two of the morning cuz
i'm also going to catch my west coast
peeps because that's the mindset of that
time not necessarily for the afternoon
when they're getting on the bus from the
regular jolly so it's you know it's
collecting data all these different data
points they're all context I don't know
how to go any deeper than the fact that
it's not you know you keep saying except
the whole time since a mistake laughs
and swim in it so here turnabout so
she's my life right like it stopped the
I topics like it's just how excited like
a business so I'll contextualize it
messes but most of my advice if it's
human like you know and that's you know
you just have to know how to be a pro
you act the same way in a funeral as you
do in a business fetal as you do in las
vegas even though all these people are
the same you have respect context it is
the real variable so again
hey there everything's bird thank you so
much for your work I was a car since and
he's like reasonable doubt you know in
the sense and I go back and I pick up
new things you know enzyme which are
treated that's shouldn't lie so my
question is uh it's actually based off a
speech I saw you doing on you did this
whole spiel about giving in the first
question the guy comes up tries to study
steak sauce or something and so my
question is you talked a lot about
giving online the answer just really
over delivery and that values or people
feel like almost bad yeah refused by
yeah I want to talk to my question is
about so offline so we make
relationships weren't have been here
people are going to be people I think
that sometimes we'll meet someone even
ask them the right way sometimes they
delay in wouldn't what are your
strategies are nuances for when offline
in a relationship do you say they know
what I want to make a house with this
person how do you think about that it's
great question so you know I live my
online life exactly the same way of my
life line like I think it's one insane
look you know they're saying three
questions I don't world here you slept
out like let's do nine right it's always
happening you know listen there were
times that it's appropriate to do and
ask right away it happens I hate it I
hate when there's a moment where
something happens where I feel it's
appropriate for me to ask right away
because I've given up my leverage
whoever asks first is in second place
right I truly believe that I do believe
that a by asked first I've lost leverage
in the relationship I feel like whether
I subconsciously maybe because I'm old
school but immediately I feel like I
mean a few times it happens I like so
panicky I'm over-delivering for that
person like TEDx right like I'm just
doing jump to share to go like it's just
it's so difficult for me to go there
that's why natural demeanor that is not
everybody's natural demeanor that's not
right by default everybody's demeanor is
the other way and I get it listen every
day that I'm more successful it's easier
for me to be patient right I get it I'm
not naive but even when I wasn't this
was my game because I know the game is
wrong i'm not patient because i can
afford to be impatient because the game
is played a lot longer than we think
about it you're going to be a
professional you're gonna be a human
being for the bigger hole lobby right
like everybody in this room except for a
couple of youngsters in the ground are
on the clock right now until it's over
so you know i think that there's a lot
of ways to provide value you know it's
not just about buying and selling you
know one thing though you people that
are doing the best is they collect
people and they do a lot of matchmaking
I think that a lot of you can do that
poorly they're literally collecting
people
to do matchmaking for the sake of having
that leverage I think we can smell that
and I think that one thing I can leave
you with is please remember that intent
deeply matters your intentions is
something we can actually feel it's how
humans are out of the [ __ ] radars
are much better than we give each other
credit for I think the reason for me
it's always worth is my intent is pure
because just as I give and the selecting
people get confused New York Times that
a huge profile me in October about me in
this book and I think they took a little
bit of a cynical shot at thing because
in one part they were like everything
Aaron does is with the intent to sell
them on something eventually I was like
that's a really sad way to look at it
here's how I look at it I give I did
that interview I do this tonight I give
I meet with people talk about go to
football players friend movie I give
because it enables me to have the
opportunity to maybe ass I'm not
entitled I don't just like gate doesn't
mean now you know I can't because I
don't know I'm gonna go really real with
you the reason i did is so insane it's
gonna make some of your head spin right
now here's why i love to get more than
anything else I give for two for one
major reason first of all let me say
this I don't need any of you I don't
talk about the camera I'm gonna get my
I'm just that good okay so I'm not doing
it because I need to get something I'm
doing it for such a crazy reason the
reason I want to give so much is in case
something insane happens and what I mean
insane I mean like world war three the
reason i like to give is me as if i give
if i'm [ __ ] bomb blows up half of
America me my finger the west coast and
I need to shack
one of you I really hope that I gave
or get a more real way that I'm very
scared up if I really give you know if I
get paralyzed in a car accident because
the one thing I need the most about
traveling so much is when other people
are driving I don't like not being the
controlling that you know I was and
these letters look at the phone the
whole time look at the road you know you
know if I get hurt I hope that I gave so
much to so many people that if my
daughter you know like one of me listing
meal is your notification of Turks and
Caicos and come with that plane goes
down and I have two young children i'm
serious i know it's dark and it's weird
but that's what I like giving because
it's gives me peace to know that I've
given us so many people some of those
[ __ ] thousands of people going to
step up and help me shut or this a nap
it's good to give its leverage it's the
right thing and so to me the answer to
your question is you can do it you just
need to recognize what's happening which
is you going to second place you know
you know how always asking I can't
default into thinking that somebody's
got my back yeah so there's bigger
things in that cake sale and so you know
what you can provide value min and we
get all four x value we can like you can
provide out a crazy place you know like
just don't just wait when I was a kid I
just shoveled people's libraries for
them on social I letters now with my
neighbor if I needed some help like I
just always been there some of the
charge thank you my needs Joe
probably don't remember this but you had
dinner with meeting about 15 co-workers
that our company headquarters and I
don't get paid a lot but that was a
really awesome and yeah I'm fine
Institute oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
amazing and I took like three vacation
knows my own Austin I put my question is
on how do you evaluate talent and how do
you bring the right people on Teen
Belgrade people like when you're going
through old sales when I was 16 that
sets up this guy was an idiot he was
pretty bad human being and I basically
dislike him but he said one thing to me
when I was 16 he loved in case I was
carrying a case of absolut vodka 1.75 to
the winter session and stopping the
wheel Old scummy you but he saw me and
we had a little talk and he said
something to be that I'll never forget
and I translated it into my own versions
the answer to your question he said Gary
he goes you don't know what you have
until you sleep with it that's the kind
of duty
and that's answered your question the
way I got him in talent is I try my best
to intuitively feel like yeah she's got
it like let's give her a shot but the
truth is until she walks in and actually
huge for 30 days I really don't know and
you read you know pretty quickly once
they're in but evaluating Italian talent
up front is very difficult like I feel
like I have the best people skills ever
I can feel that I've been wrong and so
that's people fit into this notion of
try your best it's not about hiring it's
about firing that's the key it's not
about who you let in it's how you get
them out if they're not right that's the
skill that we shall be focusing on
because you're going to miss too many in
the upfront and so you know that's how I
do it I you know I'm an optimist I'm a
half last full guide like nobody wants
to be interviewing a video via because
people walk in they be no skills on me
but I feel it this kid's got it pretty
tight
no chump like Wall Street is going to be
a ninja like I'm bad everyone I think
everybody can do it so they kind of
tried to take me out of the equation of
hiring and Boehner but that I always
clown done like but I hired you [ __ ]
so to answer your question is I don't
know I don't know a White Russian I
don't even think about it is a not
worried about that heart I'm word enough
second the second chest movement once
you come in evaluating that I know once
you're in my walls I know I know a good
work is I know what Hustle is I know
what execution is I know how you treat
the other boys and girls in the office
is I know all that so it's easy for me
quickly evaluate half of the fact i'm
not scared of somebody sneaking it I'm
sure let me say hi with social fulcrum
and my boss loves so much thank all the
employees in our company to bug but it
won't say thank you so much for sharing
so tell your boss from ipod well so my
question was recently I read this
article on time in connect me and it
basically was just talking about
Facebook and how they predicted that
facebook movie dead in three to five
years yeah I'm and is my question to use
whether or not
bill that social media is limited in our
time in our generation or whether or not
you know it's something that still
evolving will kind of laughter okay
secret waiting Facebook the Sochi you
asking you and the Facebook place long
term or the social a long-term oh okay
so here's how I look at this stuff
that's on my facebook bought instagram
instagram is to all the people that say
facebook is dead right so i think these
books i just wrote an article on
linkedin today about this which is
here's twenty one of you on this all of
us when we're in our teens and our 20s
our job is to go to every new club every
new restaurant you're just checking
everything out it's how we roll then
when you get into early 30s mid 30s you
settle down you get married your your
significant other you've got in for
favorite spots right you know specially
in your 40s and 50s United favorite
spots you go to your same three to four
or five restaurants it's how you roll
that's what I think's gonna happen to
facebook I don't know what the number is
I'm actually desperately trying to
figure this out so I can really put my
stamp on it but let's call it 3430 to
everybody from 30 to 34 and above I
think stays on facebook wait longer than
people think as long as they keep doing
the right thing because you know the
48-year old aunt and the 52 year old
grandparent that are on these platforms
you know they need all their friends to
snapchat or behind or all these other
things and that's going to take a lot
more work than people think it took them
four [ __ ] years to get comfortable on
facebook they're not going to run so
fast underneath that makes sense but
this is
headline reading yes you know when
you're 22 you don't want to go to the
same club that your mom's at right so of
course you're going to go to find and
snapchat and Instagram but facebook
bought instagram i mean it's crazy to
sleep on facebook sucks is a much
smarter much better executor than I
think people realize I think it's a very
strong CEO I think they'll be fine ish
exchange I mean things move so quickly
but there's a reason friendster died if
you want to take an old-school French
stir died because they couldn't scale
the servers weren't up and for some of
your old cats and heater like me it just
was too slow it just broke hey bro
that's why they [ __ ] lost next
myspace they sold it to a big-ass
company that didn't know what to do with
it that's why it lost so like Facebook's
very different as far as social we will
never the cats out of the bag we will
never stop communicating with each other
in picture and word form that game is
over that it's takes forever hey fella
you have their whole books
hi Gary I in question about fundraising
torturing a quaint India and i'm the
founder of a consumer goods company and
unfortunately the categories being on
the Kickstarter which is one of the
better crowdfunding sites and even on
kickstarter the maximum value can raise
around 50,000 and the barrier to entry
to launch a consumer goods plan to get
at least one to two products is well
more than 50,000 that being said the
early stage VCS have been tapped out by
Dollar Shave carries and bevel no one so
I'm just wondering what your advice is
my teens really do the very had an asset
to paint Genie at our last company but
yeah the fundraising than the most
challenging we do have interest from
Barneys but you know you're going to
trip around you are do you want to sell
the product about to put sewer or do you
want me to multi shelf but primarily
cars so you know I think I've said this
a couple times I've said it a lot
publicly but I'll do you really
interesting answer the reason I started
at vaynermedia four years ago is it's a
10 to 15-year plan for me to start
consumer package of the products so the
way i think i'm gonna buy the year of
jess is by launching consumer packaged
goods when i look at how I'm going to
make my millions I don't see hedge fund
that I don't see Facebook I see vitamin
water and grey goose and jevona yogurt
so you know because I've been spending a
lot of time thinking about this space
you know this is one of those times
Master is love you but I'll go reverse
I've got a network of cpg centric angel
Vesper vapors of love to be pardoned
introduce you the problem is there's not
a lot of people right now worried about
that space but you know I was the first
semester birchbox what you normally
Taylor it hard right so consumer
packaged goods is like where I want to
roll and so I don't think the early
stage PCs are tapped out by one of your
how are you sir it's dollar shave their
so plenty from that if you're playing
directly in Ben's kind of like grooming
maybe is that what your play on so and
then you've got other you know the
glorious launches Baxter anything it's
it's an ayah and it's at eight that's
right and so you're talking about them
it's a private space no question but I
born active look I have a west where I
was it into the ticket comes near here
ya eeka lesson in the marketing brother
what should be no 34 from your seat
Electrical morning yes sir so I have a
branch in step a little pleasure so I
have brand that it's a pair of brand
that deal with like adventure and having
a really busy life and rolling around
the park one day with my kid and then
wearing the same clothes to work like
right after right okay so there's a big
opportunity for social media because I
people bring my closing like Africa
climbing mountains going to the office
next day crib right in the same clothes
awesome so so I need shower Rochelle I
assume they're wearing my shower gel
what I mean you know
where's the key but yeah so so you know
I have I did really well kick started
with the video and yes um I think I
think I have a good voice to blogging
writing one of the things I'm hesitating
is I'm writing about my life it's part
business yeah part adventure apparel
yeah part kid yeah oh and you go back to
business as a lot of fear and they're
right so we put all that together and
when you meet about blogging alike focus
but you're starting a blog make that
blog focus on a very concise topic and
I'm like that's not me that's not my
life that's not my voice so do I focus
or do I just plays it I mean they're
talking to the guy who literally when he
did his wife show and when you've logged
in we put up tweets not only talk about
wine but this time try for segue into
business talk not just why everybody was
telling me how stupid I was and you're
the wine I saved by that I my throne the
Jets fan wrestling fan I think the more
people can you listen there are people
that buy my books because our jets game
because I like root beer because of a
family that I I think the more chapters
of your soul that you could share with
the audience the more than if I reasons
to like you I really need that I'm a
humongous fan of it being about you and
not being about the nice when people
email me they're like hey Mary this is
question 50 times of that and i entered
the same way hey Carrie hosing Johnson
here I want to do thing make some
tuxedos should i buy the URL mr. tuxedo
man for sure jose johnson co and almost
like Jose Johnson because you're mr. Sox
cede oh man now but you might want to be
something else but you're always Jose
jobs I think
you fall in I'm a big fan i can tell him
to buy your vile just talk about all
your talk about everything talk i love
talking about the fact that i keep my
bed when I was 12 that's annoying right
like talk about everything I think it's
a very important thing Iran is open to
all content may have 20 consistent and
you have to post you don't do every day
at 6pm or edible I love using exercise
of the analogy I love you you have to be
[ __ ] but if you do it every day you have
more at-bats to win listen if you see
why if you're talking about a lot of
things sometimes you burned out to talk
about the apparel one more time but if
your daughter to tell favorite or
something something really funny that
that might be something or you want to
socially commentate on the Golden Globes
last night like it just the morn you're
just about yourself we listen there's
never a day that you go by or even
nothing to talk about you whole [ __ ]
day not talking about the silent you
know but when you may go a whole day
without talking about a subject matter
so more you open it up everything first
what makes you dramatically more human
now do I think you should happen unless
you want to be a personal brand just
like celebrity for say the celebrity
person I believe check out with jarred
him in a genre and I think consistency
matters I mean I did Wine Library TV
every day five days a week for five and
a half years you know edit by the way
did it for 19 months street before
anybody gave a [ __ ] so it's not only
consistency it's perseverance up front
when nobody gives a [ __ ] oh just show me
that it looks pleased force on you in
the new format silvery isn't dead
hi how would you suggest to trimmins
amana in its meet you how would you
convince top management in a regulated
industry such as health care to kind of
move forward in social media and other
kinds of trends that in social media
that are you know saying I can do really
do answer because a lot of this and we
have a health clinic life of the web we
do a lot of farm and we do a lot of
alcohol it's hard it's very very hard
especially heavily regulated it's hard
in general or corporate a member of
utilities it's extremely hard english i
think the number one thing that I've
seen well consistently is full staff
full company education keynote talks
rattling education how do we solve all
problems we actually right and so it's
been stunning to me then like a talk
that I gave a camel soon you know what
I'm work led to it and so like if you
really have a lot of passion for it
setting up a digital day where you bring
in a lawyer from something that's a
competitor or star in health care maybe
bringing a financial service lawyer from
city that talks about their social media
policy you map it you bring a speaker
that looks like me like I go and I
diamond [ __ ] i want to be a Sorak lee
legacy correct I don't want their
business so you need people to talk to
truth but the only thing that I've seen
these companies that I've seen them in
my eyes have seen it happen has been
this education forum getting senior
leadership when they do they're off
sites getting the right don't get the
safe speaker don't get the same I think
that is really been the biggest way I've
seen it actually happened and if they're
not willing to do that and they are
willing to get involved in social media
in some way and then elevating it to the
next level while trying to follow trends
at the same time which say you know move
to pinterest or be more human in your
voice whereas they are not wanting to do
something that'll eyes with these kinds
of trends what would you say I'm
security job I'm joking you know why I
was a funny thing to say I'm dead
serious I'm not saying you don't miss
very very hard to move it somebody's not
willing to move you know I here's the
best piece of ice in your situation I
think it's a really good piece of bison
don't waver from what you believe and
keep over communicating here's why
you're historically going to be right
and those people aren't going to be gone
forever they're going to leave that
company goes somewhere else we're now
three years from now it's more accepted
and they're going to remember that you
are historically right and they're going
to bring you in to empower you that is a
really good way to think about it hello
sure do you think snapchat marketing is
the new wave of social media marketing
IV snapchat marketing for a demo that's
12 to 25 can be highly effective because
we were actually paying attention to the
content right I mean when you look at a
snap you're actually consuming it cuz
you know what's gonna disappear that was
a psychology that I was always
interested in you know when I see
something up there so many Twitter I
think I'm gonna see it again I think I
can come back to it I think somebody are
soon going to you I think it's going to
come to me and I know when I hold down
that button I'm only in the series 9 10
seconds and then i'm done i've done some
really effective marketing on snapchat
it works people paying attention it's
not going to followers man it's having
to pay attention and convert and that's
why snapchat works yes sir my name is
curtis jewel and you were mentioning the
power personal branding yeah i work for
digital agencies that's named for our
CEO but he's very introverted so
interesting about using that personal
brand yeah I'm here I'm sure Lisa
brightening well actually a thing it's
like I'm here representing the company
want to also in a larger my own personal
pressure but again i'm representing is
as well to have a trick i'm just not
sure out a breakthrough that without
doing this respect to the company that's
a really good question you know I'm
really struggling right now in vaynor
because a lot of my employees
has to be on this panel can I speak and
I'm saying no and I'm super scared if
they think that I'm trying to suppress
them so they can't build up their game
the reason I'm doing that I don't feel
confident that everybody in my
organization has their POV down on
everything if they're on stage and say
yes that's bad that automatically even
if it's Carol or Susie or Tommy and
Johnny that reflects on me and I can't
have anything be wrong now go that way
we're trying to roll right yeah I get it
man it's really really tough it's really
tough I let my employees do whatever I
want them to all be bigger than me and
what have you because I believe in
capitalism you know suppressing people
from not being able to do their thing
that's communism I came for that it's
bad so you know I think the number one
way to fix every issue in the world is
communication if this is something
that's deep in your heart I would go and
have a talk with your CEO really listen
I want to put out videos I want to do
blocks I'm aware that that sets us area
where I may get recruited but for the
time being I think it's also going to
bring it a lot of business for you maybe
if it does you can do better for me
maybe you know I don't know how you feel
we love this view the student ID rather
feel like maybe you'd say don't listen I
want to just be the best shot I can't so
if I can be your right-hand man I don't
want my own agency I don't want to work
anywhere else I just think that listen
this is an answer for everybody there's
something weirds been going on this
finale a lot in my life lately I've
always been a big proponent of over
communicating has been some really
highly
sensitive issues for employees with
family my own family where I've been
pushing this it's just stunning it
always works either you're going to
speed on the bad thing or it's going to
make it way better and so I would tell
you this is a real day in your heart you
should have talked thank you here yeah
so I'm Mike ambassador bringing and i'm
working on a start-up all brand inside
of a brand brand inside already so
basically what I'm looking to do is get
the last one was that interesting
because basically what I'm looking to do
is connect take companies and help them
to turn their actual employees until
marketing arm for them you know that's a
very big human right on people to space
right now and that's where I'm trying to
connect the question for you is is
connecting to Colorado yes employee
advocacy is social course did you um
dynamic signal that's right so some of
those folks which in those cases a lot
of times they provide a platform but as
I say the strategy for hey company let
me take you through the steps of how you
actually wanna do want to the
vaynermedia version you want to the
product you want to do that is something
abstract yes and the number one that you
should do is reach out to some chorus
and now you're the signal demarcus stuff
so my boys don't want to all these
people and ask them how do you feel
about that because they're calling to
say no our account people are doing that
but it'd be interesting for me to see
how they would respond to that because
they may actually want to support you
because you be a third party not just
them and that would rise all ships yeah
what I look at this
as I was actually that employee I was a
disgruntled employee who became a brand
ambassador and that changed everything
sure and then I started working on
revamping the program like that totally
tell you guys something in here the
number one day I don't even want
anything people sort of business is to
scratch your own inch so right here you
say that that already need to
dramatically more confidence because you
scratched your own edge let it live it
number two I would highly recommend
blocking and putting on a lot of content
the biggest mistake people have with a
lot of soul forgive you and stuff is
they think that their IP their ideas is
what they are selling rate holding I
think go to the other way I buddy I'm
vaynermedia that's gotten 20 to 300
employees pretty much predicated on
strategy and I put out of twenty
thousand bucks right like like I just
put it out there i think one thing you
should really have a lot of love do is
put it out there right blog then repeat
social course reviews that every symptom
are like brand yourself as that guy in
that space put out lots of content on
your thoughts put out fake scenarios
that you know reveal scenarios I think
that Tata has you know no one everybody
miss Ruth you're always one blood of
those are you changing your whole
business you really are it's rare but if
you're gonna you know it my unchangeable
business it just might be to your first
client which starts your business Thank
You Daniel you guys
now here
all right before everybody we can I just
say one thing I know a lot of people
here they have books and I wanted to a
picture I spreads so much to live
outside oh so sorry you can stop by my
office next week if you want
I